good looking a glamorous snatch snatch
today snatched to the hat i have a
corset on right now that i i can feel
my ribs they're hurting honey how are
you going to do that until 11. i don't
know and i have to present i i don't
know we're going to find out maybe i'll
have a drink or something you know
that'll take all the worries at all
happy early birthday young lady thank
you i know two more days what a way to
celebrate i know this is amazing i'm
seeing all my friends bothering all of
them i love bothering everybody so
thanks guys for putting this together
for me yeah exactly thank you happy
birthday to me
well uh things are good in your
neighborhood quite literally you and
david i mean that was cute wasn't it
yeah it just kind of happened but you
and david get it yeah
not even stumbled upon this viral
sensation but it became viral really do
you think through social media through
tick tock yeah i i love tick tock but i
can't believe how
how crazy it is i mean i put a video up
and it like guarded like 16 million
views it just like blew my i can't even
believe it to this day
and it's just blown up the song and it's
just amazing and i'm so blessed i'm so
happy to be here i mean you and david
are no strangers to this industry we
love dance music you could say to dance
dance too yeah yeah you always bring it
we love to dance i mean are you
surprised with like social media right
now is really it's changing yeah it's
changing the game you know usually you
go first and it's like usually radio
first and then you hope like from there
it like grabs people yeah but now it's
the other way around it's social media
wow is david can be here tonight no he's
not he's an ibiza well but i'm meeting
him of course i'm meeting him in ibiza
for your birthday now for my birthday
we're shooting the music video there oh
i mean only if you don't come with me if
you'll come with me then okay
make it happen will you guys pay for her
ticket it's quite exp i mean i i could
pay for your ticket it's crazy though
baby let's go i will carry your bags
let's go
[Music]